[Music]
this morning on the dish we take you to
Los Alamos California and while it's a
small town it's now on the world
culinary map thanks to a husband and
wife Duo and their acclaimed restaurant
Jamie wax had a chance to visit and got
a taste Jamie good morning good morning
Michelle and a taste is Right Bells is
located along California's Central Coast
about an hour north of Santa Barbara but
while it's off the beaten path
enthusiastic diners have certainly
managed to find it it's earned glowing
reviews and earned Chef Daisy Ryan a
coveted Michelin star
the term Farm to Table is overused in
the restaurant business but it's an
actual description of Chef Daisy Ryan's
daily commute
Daisy this is where you start your
morning
here at Findlay Farms the Finley
surprised me every day what's surprising
you today lately we've had these really
beautiful blackberries I mean largest
I've ever seen truly uh blackberries
that are grown here on Family Farm yeah
they're pretty awesome really good
awesome right so good that fresh produce
from California's Central Coast
it is also Central to the dishes served
by Chef Ryan and her husband Greg at
their French inspired Bistro Bells
booney tureen tartar
serves a Cuisine they jokingly refer to
as French it's French and Ranch yes yeah
exactly it's as rural as can be and
what's fresh but it also has a little
little touch of French in it it is a
good descriptor for what we do because
they're hopefully is a perceived level
of finesse and sophistication and maybe
a little bit more fine dining in the way
that we do things however there is still
this Simplicity
um not necessarily rustic but something
that is not quite so Pomp and
Circumstance about the food and we got
to sample some of it starting with
escargot cooked with parsley pernot
garlic and butter this is the most I
will say herbaceous and garlicky like in
the best way escargot I ever had my
whole life thank you I can't wait to
hear again and I'm gonna soak all the
rest of it up with this bread also on
the table uni crepe a Santa Barbara sea
urchin on layered crepes with Creme
Fresh topped with caviar this is a
perfect bite I mean this really is and
this is how everybody starts their meal
at dinner we do a small bite of this
steak crusted with peppercorn and
accompanied with fruits we talk about it
being our connection and Nod towards the
way that we started this restaurant in
it being a very traditional French
Bistro
gorgeously medium rare let's take a pois
at its best that is unbelievable Dell's
Farm Fresh Salad and for dessert
champagne moose
this is so beautifully delicate and
fluffy but but also salty not just sweet
but salty and that little bit of salt
brings out these figs like crazy it's
delicious
the restaurant has helped transform the
quaint town of Los Alamos that's
especially important to Chef Daisy a
native of the area who set out on a
non-traditional career path starting in
culinary school and then in Hospitality
for the legendary Thomas Keller and
Danny Meyer
I loved cooking I like the high
intensity of it there is an artistic
element it's athletic in many ways so I
always intended on cooking but I had an
instructor at the CIA that said hey
you're really good in the dining room
and per se is looking for team members
in the dining room it was at per se that
she met her partner in life and in
business at the heart of this is a love
story a love story about home love story
about food and a love story between two
people yeah and somebody asked me like
what is your concept and Greg and I kind
of look at each other and go well our
it's our life you know it is it is just
the things that we love and and are just
really excited that other people love
those things too and it's just it's
worked out I think that's why we feel it
when we're diners here the pair bonded
in New York then moved together to La
Austin and eventually back to the Santa
Ynez Valley largely because of the
encouragement of the chef parents I have
a great relationship with my mom and dad
they're really the reason that I became
interested in food and wine and
restaurants and my dad is a very
ambitious person and he's like well
let's just buy a restaurant let's do
something let's make it happen it felt
like a place that we could actually make
a difference and make an impact and they
have definitely done that Bells has
become a dining destination and Ryan has
garnered accolades along the way
including being named food and Wine's
best new chef and being awarded a
coveted Michelin star
do you remember the moment you found out
yeah you become
um like emotional just because it's not
something that we ever really searched
for it's not anything that we were
ambitious about
um but that someone decided to
acknowledge something that you did
um
on on your own terms you think Ritz
crackers both Daisy and Greg say they're
anxious to use what they've learned to
help others in the industry this
restaurant is is kind of what we this is
what we have to say everything else that
might come our way or that we decide
that we want to try and do is through
collaboration of others and hopefully
uh offering them an opportunity to give
them a chance to say something as well
and for Chef Daisy Ryan that goal is
especially personal do you hope that
you're an inspiration for young women
who want to run a kitchen sure I hope to
set a standard and be a leader for for
younger people
so we have a game here from they have
one of the greatest wine lists in the
country this is from the region from the
Santa Ynez Valley oh my gosh
and yes cheers cheers cheers and uh I
will say Los Alamos was a food
destination without bells but they
really came in but there are some other
great places to go it's a tiny town
where you can spend days just having a
great time and you said they're open on
Monday yes they're open on Mondays
because all the chefs from Los Angeles
and the region come to eat on their
night off really yes that's the truth
they are a Chef's Restaurant what a sign
of respect absolutely always love
hearing the stories about when they find
out they're they have a Michelin style
it's great yeah